good evening everyone
thank you all for coming it's a pleasure
to be your keynote speaker tonight
um thank you to all the conference staff
who put all this together of the NDC
conferences are always a great time for
the speakers
uh so I'm Kyle and I'm here to talk
about the Boeing 737 Max a plan that
you've probably heard about in the media
it was a Hot Topic back in 2019 just
before kovitz stole the spotlight
uh I nobody actually told me I was going
to be the party speaker tonight
um
I mean I should have seen it coming
because in in Oslo last year when I was
there uh Henriette told me that I had
been declared an edutainment speaker
um which is a bit of a blow to my
academic self-esteem but I'll take what
I can get uh so with that in mind I'm
gonna try to switch it up a little bit
and keep it a bit lighter than I usually
do I mean obviously it's a very serious
topic and so uh the party speech was an
interesting choice but
um I'm happy to make it work
so I've been trying to think of some
other titles that might be more fun
um you know when humans and Technology
don't mix it it gets the point across
but maybe how to irreparably damage your
company in three easy steps
how to get a 62 million dollar CEO
retirement package
it takes 102 years to build a reputation
and two crashes to destroy it
so when I do this I also like to have
some audience interaction because it's
fun right it keeps things interesting
gets everyone engaged and normally we do
this with like a who here has done
something is something and get a show of
hands but that's boring so we're not
going to do that
instead in the spirit of where we are
when I ask this question if it applies
to you School
nice and loud with energy
similarly uh when I ask somewhat
rhetorically was this a good idea or
does this sound like a good idea you can
either respond with absolutely nice and
loud or hell no it is not a good idea
so let's do some trial runs here who
here is enjoying the conference
was it a good idea to come
all right
who had to fly to get here
all right when I was flying on a Boeing
plane across the Atlantic to get here I
was watching and taking notes on on a
documentary about Boeing planes crashing
um the passengers around me and the
flight attendants were getting a little
uncomfortable was that a good idea
a mixed reaction on that but yeah so a
bit about me I'm Kyle I went to MIT to
do my PhD there in aerospace engineering
focusing on humans and Aerospace human
systems integration basically how we
Design Technology uh complex
technological systems for humans to be
able to operate them efficiently and
safely without harming the systems or
harming the humans
and after I did that I started my own
company in victim Labs we focus on
prototyping of various systems Hardware
software Cloud iot that kind of stuff
and we're based in Ottawa which is the
beautiful national capital of Canada
and I also work with a company called
top towel which is a Global Network of
Freelancers who are pretty skilled at
what they do and they basically bring
you clients which is very nice for me
what I'm going to talk about today I
want to note are things to consider
right we're talking about pretty high
level Concepts uh there's way too much
technical detail for me to be giving
prescriptive instructions on what you
should or should not do so we're talking
about things to think about when you're
designing your systems not directions on
how to do it
and we come to this topic called human
factors engineering human systems
integration it's all kind of tied
together and when I say this word you
know people say okay I know what that is
that's ux and UI right I do that
and that's true it does include those
components but it's much more than just
that you have your biomechanics how
bodies move and operate
sensory input how you actually collect
information from your different senses
often we usually use visual we always
use Visual and sometimes audio but when
we start talking about more complex
systems particularly aircraft we start
getting into haptic feedback as well
which is touch the sense of touch and
we'll get into that a bit more later
cognitive processing how you actually
process all this information you're
getting and what you do with it
ergonomics which is how you design
things like cockpits such that Pilots
can sit in them and actually reach all
the different controls under things like
high g-forces or other weird conditions
and then mental models which is
something we're going to come back to
again later which is this idea that in
your mind you understand what the system
is thinking and you're thinking in the
same way So This Together encompasses
human factors engineering
and I also want to touch on life
critical systems I think a lot of people
come to my talk thinking hey aircraft
are cool I want to learn about them and
them crashing
and well let's get a show of hands who
here is here because aircraft are cool
okay thank you
uh but it's it's it does include
aircraft yeah but it's so much more than
that and the reason that I think this is
kind of relevant to this particular
conference where there's been a number
of talks on embedded and life critical
Mission critical systems is that so many
different topics can be considered life
critical so many different pieces of
software in an airplane for example
obviously you have your avionics your
engines your Control Systems
um fuselage anything that can that if it
breaks you're going to crash those are
all life critical but it's also
everything else right you think about
the coffee pot in the galley if that
software fails and that boils over and
overflows and the liquid drops down
through the through the floorboards and
shorts out some circuits that is life
critical system now right or it burns
one of the flight attendants who might
be critical for some operation of the
aircraft
Emergency Services anything to do with
them their communication systems or
vehicles or tools obviously live
critical telecommunications is a is one
that people don't often think about this
way because I mean hey ktello
Communications fail my cell phone
doesn't work I can't text my grandma my
cat pictures but it's actually much more
important because now I can't call
Emergency Services right A lot of people
elderly people in some countries need to
be able to phone their prescriptions
into a pharmacy to have them filled and
delivered or you can't call your family
to come take care of you if you need
help
so all of a sudden telecommunications as
a whole becomes life critical Automotive
especially with the Advent of
self-driving cars anything that fails
there is going to drive you into a wall
at 100 kilometers per hour
definitely life critical Healthcare not
only things like surgical robots IV
pumps anything that actually
medicates you or does surgery on you but
also all the software that is used by
healthcare workers to maintain your
medical records for example your medical
record disappears or the system shows
the wrong information and all of a
sudden a physician is prescribing you
something you're allergic to life
critical military also obviously
anything they touch is life critical by
Design
but things can go wrong with the systems
they use and there's a lot of research
in there
so with that who here has ever worked on
a life critical system of any type
let's say it's about a third of the room
right which is pretty decent for a
system like this
and I also want to say this is not
theoretical we're trying to keep this
light and fun because it's the party
talk but it's also important to keep in
mind that this is something serious that
actually happened that a lot of people
died from it and there are a lot of
families that are still mourning that so
we just need to keep that in mind as we
go through this
and I used to say when I first started
doing the stock a couple years ago that
I'm not assigning blame Boeing please
don't sue me yada yada yada but the
investigations are done now and we can
definitively say
that they are at fault
um the Boeing was actually criminally
charged with uh trying to defraud the
FAA and settled that charge for 2.5
billion dollars
so let's talk about what actually
happened
our first flight was Lion Air Flight 610
this is October of 2018 and it crashed
into the Java sea off the coast of
Indonesia at over 560 kilometers per
hour that was the last recorded speed it
probably was going much faster than that
when it actually hit and that killed all
189 people on board
and then about six months later we had
Ethiopian Airlines flight 302 uh crashed
into terrain which is the ground at 926
kilometers per hour and that killed 157
people on board
and this had a huge worldwide impact the
737 Max was grounded worldwide
three days after the second crash
that included 387 aircraft that had
already been delivered that affected 59
Airlines and canceled 8 600 flights per
week for 20 months that is a lot of
flights that were canceled
it resulted in an audit of the FAA
regulatory process basically the U.S
government said FAA clearly screwed up
we need to investigate what happened and
that caused quite a quite a kerfuffle in
the US government
and then one of the more important ones
is uncertainty around the world and
other regulatory bodies up until this
point most governments in their Aviation
regulate regulators
said okay Boeing aircraft was
manufactured in the U.S the U.S has a
relatively reliable government so if the
FAA says that it's safe we're just going
to trust that it's safe and let it fly
through our airspace and land at our
airports well clearly that wasn't true
right because the FAA said this aircraft
is fine and so now all of a sudden all
these countries around the world are
like okay do we actually need to start
doing our own evaluations of all these
different aircraft and that is a massive
undertaking
in terms of what actually resulted from
that 20 billion dollars in fines for
Boeing 60 billion dollars in canceled
aircraft orders Boeing is a massive
company but 80 billion dollars is still
a massive hit to their pocket
over seven billion dollars in costs for
the Airlines and the uh because the
aircraft couldn't fly
and 100 million dollars in Lost income
for Pilots now that number seems small
compared to everything else up there but
the pilots Union in the U.S is quite a
powerful body that has a lot of sway
with the FAA and the Airlines and the uh
air manufacturers and there is no better
way to piss off a group of Pilots than
to deprive them of 100 million dollars
so that actually played quite a role in
these proceedings
looking at the timeline of how we got
here so the the 737 is a legendary
aircraft right it's the longest flying
aircraft that Boeing has produced and
it's been around for almost 60 years at
this point
but in 2006 they said okay this thing's
gone through so many revisions it's old
it's time to design a new replacement a
clean sheet design which means we start
with a blank piece of paper nothing gets
carried over from the old design
but then in 2010 Airbus which is
Boeing's primary competitor launches the
A320 Neo they announced that this is
going to be flying soon now the A320 is
important to note is very similar in
size and capability and range to the 737
they're direct competitors in the same
Market space
and Neo here stands for new engine
option so basically Airbus which has
also been flying the A320 for a long
time said we're just gonna take the old
engines off we're going to put some
bigger more efficient engines on it
leave everything else the same and call
it a new plane and the airlines love
this because it's the plane they know
and love except now it's more fuel
efficient which is a big impact for them
and shortly after that they set up a
record of selling these plants 730 at a
single Air Show which is way more than
any previous number and the month after
that American Airlines orders 260 of
them and what's really important here is
that up until this point American
Airlines had exclusively flown Boeing
aircraft right American Airlines
American aircraft it's a match made in
heaven but this new A320 Neo is so
appealing that they decided to scrap
that and introduce an entirely New
Logistics chain from Europe just to be
able to fly this aircraft and this
scares the hell out of Boeing because
it's a sign of bad things to come if one
of their biggest customers is now making
this change but at the same time
American Airlines also orders a bunch
more 737s but asks Boeing to put more
efficient engines on them
and so Boeing says okay
we're going to have to make these
re-engined 737s for American Airlines
anyways so let's just scrap the idea of
a new plane and we'll put all our
efforts into developing a new version of
the 737 which we'll call the max
and in 2016 the A320 Neo has its first
Revenue flight meaning the first flight
operated by an airline is carrying
passengers and in 2017 Boeing has their
first 737 Max flight so through this
process Boeing pretty much accomplished
what they were trying to do of keeping
up with Airbus and having a new plane to
Market
why does any of this matter okay more
efficient engines are larger
this is a picture of the engine on the
original 737 right 1.25 meters in
diameter it's called a low bypass engine
you can see it's quite narrow and this
is fine this is what the plane was
originally designed for
we skip over to the third generation the
Next Generation they called it and here
we have a much larger high bypass engine
that's 1.83 meters in diameter and then
we have the 737 Max which is now 2.26
meters in diameter and the question is
how do you fit an engine that is almost
twice the diameter of the original
engine on an aircraft of the same
original design where nothing else has
changed the answer is you can't you
cannot do that in the way that it was
intended to it doesn't fit because if
you try it looks like this and your
engine's scraping along the ground when
you are trying to take off
and that is not good for the engine
so what Boeing does is
they shift the engine forward and up
like so
and so this engine is now basically on
the front hanging off the front of the
wing but they've raised it up enough
that they have the ground clearance they
need
and we can see in a side-by-side
comparison of the different models
looking from top to bottom the original
on top has a lot of ground clearance
Small Engine which is almost directly
underneath the wing and then the bottom
the 737 Max has a much larger engine
that is just hanging off the front of
that wing
the more important piece here is how far
forward that engine is sitting because
what happens is that the nacelle the
casing around the engine uh actually
generates is such a large surface area
that it generates lift when the plane is
at a high angle of attack meaning that
when the plane is pitched up the airflow
moving past that engine generates lift
and pushes the plane up but because the
engine is not under the wing where the
center of lift should be it's forward
that lift actually pushes the nose of
the plane up and causes it to want to
pitch up even further so you have this
self-reinforcing Loop where the pilot
pitches up a little too high this effect
happens pitches up more this effect
happens more and you get into a very bad
situation very quickly and the FAA says
no it's not okay you can't do this you
can't have a plane that pitches up on
its own with no pilot input and is
unrecoverable if you don't deal with it
and boating Zone test pilots say
something similar they say we've been
flying this it doesn't feel the same as
the old 737 doesn't feel good has these
weird handling characteristics we need
you to fix it and Boeing tries a couple
things they do some Hardware changes
some aerodynamic changes to try to to
deal with this issue but they can't
really without causing major redesigns
to the aircraft
and so they decide to solve it in
software and we come to MCAS the
maneuvering characteristics augmentation
system
MCAS is an algorithm that sits on the
flight control computer
so in our in our 737 on each side of the
cockpit on the external side we have
this sensor here and this is called an
angle of attack sensor and what it does
is it measures the angle of the airflow
moving past it relative to the angle of
the plane
the angle that the plane is attacking
the air is literally what that term
means
and when that plane starts to get into
that pitching up situation
that angle of attack sensor starts
getting a very high reading
and it starts sending that data into the
flight control computer which is where
amcas is sitting and MCAS says oh we're
starting to pitch up too high this is
what we were designed for we need to fix
this situation so it sends a signal
to the uh what's called the Jack screw
at the back which controls the
stabilizers the stabilizers are those
little horizontal small wings at the
back which affect the trim and so it
sends a signal to the screw which
basically rotates these things back
which at the back of the aircraft
generates lift which brings the nose of
the aircraft down
and so this causes the plane to pitch
down like so and it stabilizes and now
it's no longer generating that
extraneous lift from the engine to sell
and we're back in a stable situation
that's the theory behind MCAS
and if we put this on a nice little
systems diagram now I should note I am
an infrastructure and back-end developer
I don't do front end work I don't do
Graphics work so this is not looking
great but uh gets the point across
so we have the sensors the angle of
attack sensors which are on the side
which are connected to the flight
control computers there are two flight
control computers one on each side of
the plane and each sensor is attached to
its own flight control computer they're
not cross-linked
and what happens is MCAS is sitting on
those flight control computers and it
sends a signal to the stabilizers at the
back which rotates them
we'll take a little break on that to
talk about something called type ratings
so a type is a category of aircraft
they'd all have similar characteristics
similar handling characteristics similar
performance characteristics and a type
rating is a certification that allows a
pilot to fly aircraft that are in a type
and type ratings are a pain to get
they're very expensive and they're very
time consuming and Airlines avoid them
at all cost because Pilots have to go
through a ground school they have to go
through a lot of time in a simulator
those simulators and many millions of
dollars each
they have to do an oral exam and they
have to do a check ride with an
instructor pilot to make sure they've
actually learned and memorized all these
skills and this whole thing takes a very
long time is very expensive not only
because of all the equipment but because
every hour that a pilot is doing this is
an hour that they're not flying for the
airline and therefore not generating
Revenue
so Airlines try to avoid this and
so we have a type here the A330 is a is
a type and we see there are different
variants within that type
and the important part is that the A320
is also a type
and if we compare two variants within
the A320 type we see why they are the
same these are two different models of
aircraft that look almost identical in
the cockpits the controls are the same
the layout's the same displays are the
same everything's almost identical so
pilot doesn't even really need to know
which variant they're flying
within a type rating the different
variants to move from one to the other
to to be approved to fly a new one
basically a pilot just has to do a brief
course on a tablet to go over some very
basic differences in performance and
weight and such and that's about it no
simulator no check ride no exam no
Ground School
and the reason the A320 Neo was so
successful is because they managed to
pull this off where they got it into the
same type rating as all the previous
a320s so all these airlines that were
already flying this the older models
could buy the new model and all their
pilots could just fly it without having
to go through all this extra training
and simulator time
now the 737 is also a type and all the
previous variants had fallen within the
same type as desired and so the question
is could Boeing get the max into the
same type category
because that's the only way they could
be competitive otherwise no one's going
to buy it if all their pilots have to go
through all this extensive training
but the problem is that MCAS is a new
control system and a new control SAS
system means a pilot needs a different
training and different training means it
gets a different type rating and a
different type rating means it's no
longer competitive and this makes Boeing
very upset because they know that no
one's going to buy their aircraft and
um it's just simply not going to sell
but they come up with a solution
and their solution is you don't tell
anyone about MCAS
because if you don't know about MCAS you
don't need training on MCAS right
and
if there's no amcast training then you
get the same training as the older 737
and if it's the same training it's the
same type rating the same typewriting
now it's a competitive aircraft and this
makes Boeing thrilled and they're very
proud of themselves patting themselves
in the back what a great solution does
this seem like a good idea
but that's what they did uh so Boeing
decided the 737 Pilots didn't need any
extra training didn't even need to know
about it wasn't in the flight manuals
well not quite they it was originally in
the flight manuals and then they were
worried about it causing this extra
training so they took it out but they
left the acronym in the glossary so the
acronym is still in the back of the
flight manual but nowhere in the manual
as it actually mentioned or used
so that allowed them to get the common
type rating with the previous models so
all the pilots could fly the max yeah
they added exactly what they were trying
to do successful
now their justification for doing this
uh As Told by Dennis muellenberg who was
the CEO of Boeing
he said that the system MCAS is
fundamentally embedded in the system and
the handling qualities of the aircraft
it's not a separate system to be trained
on basically saying that because a pilot
doesn't actually interact with it they
don't turn it on turn it off they can't
turn it on or off they don't need to
know about it because they never
actually interact with it a little
spoiler alert here Mr Muhlenberg is no
longer the CEO of Boeing
but it worked their plan worked um
training on moving to the new aircraft
took a pilot who was already type
certified uh one hour on an iPad to fly
the new airplane and that is it they're
off carrying passengers
what's interesting is that some of the
airlines they were selling this thing to
actually wanted that extra training
though they wanted the simulators they
wanted simulator time for their pilots
but Boeing did not take kindly to that
because they were worried that if some
Airlines start doing this then some of
the aviation authorities are going to
say okay I know maybe that should be a
requirement and then you have a big
problem
a text sent from one Boeing Employee to
another now friggin lion era might need
a Sim to fly the Max and maybe because
of their own stupidity I'm scrambling
trying to figure out how to unscrew this
now idiots
is this a good way to talk to your
customers
so you can see they were quite worried
about this and does anyone notice the
name of the airline in here
yeah that was the first one that crashed
so talk about their manual overrides for
MCAS
this is a cockpit of 737 a couple things
to note here on the side of the Yoke you
have these little toggle switches called
trim switches what they do is they
control the electric motor the same one
that MCAS uses which rotates the
stabilizer to trim the aircraft
and then at the bottom you have your
trim cutout switches these are just
electric switches that completely
disconnect the flight control computer
from the trim motor so that electric
motor does not function anymore
when you turn those off
then you have this manual trim wheel
which is a little wheel which is next to
the Pilot's knee
and it has a little handle that flips
out and this is mechanically linked to
the stabilizer right so there's actually
a cable that runs back
um and so when the stabilizer moves this
moves and when this moves stabilizer
moves
now if we add those to our diagram our
trim switch is somewhere up here it
sends that signal to the computers which
then sends it off to the stabilizer
motor and our cutout switch is here it
disconnects the entire system
and our trim wheel is here it is
mechanically linked it cannot be
disconnected
so details of the flights
this is a graph showing the altitude and
speed of that flight and this is not a
normal flight path
as you can see about two minutes in uh
there's this first weird situation
happens where the pi where the plane
drops in altitude suddenly picks up a
lot of speed but then they recover and
keep climbing and then more like four
five minutes in we start this weird
oscillation pattern where they're going
down and up and down and up and down and
up until eventually that overpowers them
and they drop down into the ocean
here's a little video clip showing what
um it looks like in the ocean after a
plane crashes there the components to
their left are very small and difficult
to find a lot of them are underwater
bottom of the ocean uh and it makes the
investigation extremely difficult and
long some often times they can't even
find the flight recorder or cockpit
voice recorder because they've been
damaged so bad or they're so far
underwater that they can't be found and
that makes the investigation very
difficult these were long investigations
that have finally come to a close
um but it's quite a process
so what happened here is that the angle
of attack sensor
that was connected to the active flight
control computer
uh failed somehow it started sending
erroneous data into the control computer
and it could have been a number of
things it could have been essentially it
was faulty when it was installed it
could have been a bird strike that broke
it during flight it could have been a
number of different things but it failed
and what happens then is it sends that
signal into MCAS and MCAS is getting
this this erroneous data that's saying
the plane is pitched up far too high so
MCAS activates and that triggers that
stabilizer to rotate into the trim down
position
and it does this for 10 seconds at a
time with a five second interval in
between so 10 seconds on five seconds
off and so it's that's why you're
starting to see this oscillation pattern
because it's trimming down it stops the
pilots are pulling back on the stick as
hard as they can so they're trying so it
pulls up a bit and then it happens again
so Pilots don't understand what's
happening so they try to use
um their electric trim to counteract it
it only works during the five second
period where MCAS isn't firing
uh and they go back and forth and lose
this battle and eventually mcast
overpowers them and down they go and so
now we can see why that oscillation
pattern pattern at the top there is
happening
so after this happens and they recover
the data recorder and actually get some
some sensor measurements off of it I
believe that updates at eight to eight
Hertz so it's a pretty up-to-date
um recording of the sensor measurements
and Boeing and the FAA get together and
they start reviewing this data and they
say what could have happened here and
they think they know what might have
what might have occurred because that
angle of attack sensor has very very
bizarre data
and so they put together what's called
an airworthiness directive which is
basically a bulletin that gets sent out
to all the pilots who are certified to
fly this aircraft and it tells you what
to do in the event that something like
this happens you're supposed to turn off
the autopilot and try to pull back on
the stick to pull up and then use your
mat your electric trim switch if that
doesn't work uh turn the those cut off
switches to off to disable the electric
control altogether and if it's still
having a problem then use that manual
wheel that we talked about to crank the
stabilizer into a trim up position
so all the pilots that fly this aircraft
have to read this and understand it
before they're allowed to keep flying
so now we come to our second flight
this is a chart again showing the
altitude of the aircraft over time and
we're starting to see some real
similarities here right we're seeing
about two minutes in a sudden drop and
recovery and drop some recovery in this
oscillation pattern again until
eventually uh down it goes
and this is what it looks like when an
aircraft hits the ground at 930 some
kilometers per hour
uh it's again very difficult to recover
anything it's easier than in the water
because at least the parts are still
there and accessible but it's still a
massive undertaking to try to
investigate the crash
fortunately they found the data recorder
quite quickly and were able to access
the center data off of it
so again what happened well same issue
angle of attack sensor busted don't know
why but something happened to it
MCAS activates
same thing but this time those Pilots
they've read that directive and they
recognize this right so they know that
this is what they're supposed to do so
they disabled those cutout switches
right following the instructions
and then they try to use their manual
wheel to rotate the stabilizer back into
position again following the directive
they did what they were supposed to do
the problem is that
during takeoff is one of the only times
that a plane is at Full Throttle
in a regular flight and so these Pilots
had taken off at the full throttle and
then very shortly after takeoff these
issues started coming up that it
completely distracted them from the
normal flight operations
and so this plane while they were
battling with this for quite a few
minutes the plane was still at Full
Throttle and eventually got to a speed
that was Far higher than it should have
been at that point in this flight
and because it was moving so quickly and
this stabilizer was rotated back so far
the flow of air against the stabilizer
caused so much force that the pilots did
not have the strength to rotate that
manual wheel to trim it back because
they were battling this massive amount
of air pressure against it
so they recognized this they cannot turn
the wheel
and they think that well they can't fix
it doing it manually so the only chance
they have is to reactivate that Electric
System to use the electric assist
but of course as soon as they do that
MCAS which has still been running in the
background the whole time it's just been
disconnected from what it's supposed to
actuate
um gets connected again and the
situation gets worse and it drives the
nose down into the ground
so to recap
they modified the existing design which
changed the aerodynamics of the aircraft
and they couldn't fix it is that a good
idea
they couldn't solve it without a
redesign so they solved the hardware and
aerodynamics problem in software
is that a good idea
and they didn't tell the pilots they
wouldn't have to train on it how about
that one good idea
but the pilots didn't know what's
happening right so that's how you get
accident number one which is your Lion
Air flight
they get the airworthiness directive no
they they gave you instructions on what
to do right but Boeing never actually
said what the problem is they still
haven't told anyone about MCAS at this
point
and the pilots are not physically able
to follow those instructions so you get
accent number two Ethiopian Airlines
and that kind of concludes the summary
of what happened here and so let's talk
about what we actually learned from this
and what we need to think about the
first question is when do you actually
teach users about the inner workings of
a complex system not just Aerospace or
an aircraft but any kind of very
complicated technical system that takes
a long time to learn all the details
so I want to illustrate this with an
example
let's say we have a new car
and you can tell this presentation was
made a couple years ago when that looked
like a new car
um
and this car straight out of the factory
has a defect just one defect it's very
rare it doesn't happen often unlikely
but sometimes it just accelerates on its
own and
you can't stop it
but it's rare don't worry about it
now to deal with this we have two
options option number one is what is
printed in the technical manual very
deep down in the details
and this is the proper way to fix the
problem and it's guaranteed to work so
you have to hold the accelerator pedal
at its maximum position for four seconds
while simultaneously pumping the brake
three times at one second intervals and
then you have to apply the emergency
brake at 33 for eight seconds
but
after releasing the accelerator but
before you release the emergency brake
you have to activate the four-way Hazard
flashers and apply the horn for 3.6
seconds
and if you do this properly if you
follow these directions well here's the
kicker you have to start doing it within
10 seconds of noticing there's a problem
or it's not going to work 10 seconds was
the time that the FAA later determined
that if the pilots did not respond to
the situation within 10 seconds by
following the perfect directions there
was no chance of recovery 10 second
window
if you do it within the time window
you're guaranteed to resolve your issues
it's perfect
now this seems ridiculous right but if
you've ever seen some of the checklists
that Pilots have to go through for
certain flight operations they get
incredibly complex
then you have option number two which is
you turn off the engine and you attempt
to maintain control of your vehicle
while you apply the brakes
and to have an 85 chance percent chance
of succeeding with this right you might
get into a sticky situation and crash
but you'll probably be okay
now let's say we have two users we have
your average Joe he's been driving for
15 years and you know he kind of knows
what he's doing
and you have Speedy Sally who's an F1
race car driver she spends her entire
career every day eight hours a day
training on her vehicle
given these two options which options do
you tell or provide to each of these
operators
and you generally do something like this
Joe
has no idea what he's doing there's not
a chance that he's ever going to
remember a checklist like that
and so if the situation happens
especially under stress and he's not
very well trained to deal with stress
he's not going to follow the rules and
he's going to screw it up and it's going
to crash so even though it has a
guaranteed 100 chance of success if you
do it right he's not going to do it
right so it doesn't really matter
so instead we give them the option
that's the intuitive option the common
sense approach what is not as perfect
but it's more likely for him to actually
be able to do it because he is not a
professional user
but Sally on the other hand you know
like I said she does this all day every
day she can actually memorize a
checklist like this and she can practice
it and rehearse it on the track and get
it down to the point where if it happens
within two seconds she'll be able to
respond properly
and these form two points to end points
I want to call Performance versus
knowledge curve or complexity versus
knowledge curve because often
performance and complexity go hand in
hand
and sticking with our mode of
transportation we can plot some points
on here
if we look at walking for example it's a
very low performance method of of
movement but a pretty low level of
knowledge required to do it then you
have cycling you're moving faster but
you actually have to learn how to do it
and train on it driving a car keep
moving up this scale then you have your
race car at the top
and the idea being that as your
performance of your system and
complexity of your system increases you
need to know more about how it works in
order to be able to safely and
effectively actually operate it and we
see that with our aircraft as well at
the bottom end you're starting on your
Cessna where most people pick it up as
their first plane
you start moving into commercial
airliners much more complex but much
more performance
and then you have your fighter jets near
the top where it is a career we are
spending more time training and you are
actually flying in order to be able to
operate it safely
and this applies not just to
Transportation but to all sorts of
different things we look at computers
right my grandmother has her bill stock
laptop CPU easy to use she needs to turn
it on or off and back on again and it
works fine versus my computer I've
overclocked it and to do this you get
more performance but you need to know
about voltage regulation thermal
management water cooling however else
you want to do it so you get the
performance but you need a lot more
knowledge
you can see it with your little kid skis
for the Bunny Hill versus skis that
actually have bindings right you need to
know how to use them how to tension them
how to fit them properly you see this
with your Mac computers and your Linux
computers higher performance higher
level of knowledge required
and this gets me very different
reactions depending on the conference
I'm at
I think this was the right one for this
yeah all right was that a good idea
but if we put these on our graph we see
that it follows the same Trend right
this this holds true from most systems
and most domains in most Industries
so the question here is should Boeing
have told the pilots about MCAS I think
most of us would now say yeah yeah
probably like Pilots are really expected
to know and understand most of the
systems in their aircraft that they're
flying not the Deep technical details of
how they actually work at a software
level but at least their presence and
their impact on flight parameters
but Boeing concluded that there would be
little risk in the event of an MCAS
failure because the pilots and the FAA
approved this the pilots would respond
to a failure in within three seconds
so it's okay if it breaks because the
pilots will fix it within three seconds
however Boeing the FAA agreed they
wouldn't tell the pilots about it uh
because Boeing safety analysis expected
the pilots to be uh sorry they wouldn't
tell them about it even though they were
the primary backstop
and I want to pause to note that um as
you may know Boeing was historically
headquartered in Seattle Washington they
moved their headquarters to Chicago in
the mid to late 90s in a situation that
was actually quite closely associated
with what happened to Boeing over the
following two decades but they actually
because they were in the same city they
have a long and storied history of
covering Boeing uh in the news and they
actually want to Pulitzer Prize for for
their coverage of the previous
generation of the 737 so that's why
we're looking at their quotes as a
reputable source
so they didn't tell the pilots about it
they decided not to follow that curve
and we got these accidents
the next question is how do you ensure
that your users actually know what is
happening in a complex system and this
comes back to some of those things I
mentioned about human factors
particularly mental models
we have this thing called mode confusion
particularly in aircraft because it was
a field of research that really stemmed
around aircraft and spacecraft because
in these types of vehicles you have many
different modes of the vehicle vehicle
can be operating in you have an
autopilot mode and you have an auto
throttle mode which are not necessarily
the same thing you have a takeoff
configuration and a landing
configuration and in all these different
configurations the same buttons and
switches and displays can do or show you
different things so you could press a
button expecting it to do one thing but
if it's in a different mode than what
you think it is it could do something
entirely different
and this gets very confusing for Pilots
especially when things change without
them being aware of it particularly due
to Automation in the background and this
issue comes up even before you have
things like MCAS dancing around back
there messing with your control inputs
and your flight parameters without you
being aware of it and this causes great
confusion for your pilots and it is a
theme that you see in almost every
accident major accident investigation
report is that the pilots got confused
about what was happening in the aircraft
before they crashed
very rarely is a crash due to Pure
mechanical failure usually it is due to
something breaks which causes confusion
for the pilots which they could have
recovered from if they had really
understood what was happening but they
didn't do two situation like this
and now I'm going to show you a video
this is a simulator from an Air France
flight that crashed in 2009 unrelated it
was on an Airbus
um over the uh
over the Atlantic Ocean I think it was
going from uh Brazil to Paris
and this shows you what the cockpit
sounds like during one of these
emergencies
over the next four and a half minutes
the stall warning will sound 75 times
so that's from uh documentary about the
crash but it kind of shows you that
even in this situation their the
aircraft was stalling and you can hear
that stall alarm going off 75 times do
you think they might notice after the
first time and maybe they understand the
situation but instead we're just
hammering them with that continuously
even though they already know and the
problem is that that then interferes
with other information that you're
trying to tell them such as why you're
stalling
here's another one this isn't a 747
[Applause]
so not only is it loud like those Pilots
can barely talk to each other but it's
also very stressful right you're
inducing a huge amount of adrenaline
which is not conducive to trying to
perform calm and rational actions that
you need to do to recover from this
situation
and we know that this played a role in
the 737 crashes uh there were at least
five different alarms going off in those
crashes
and in in this video you hear too so you
know times that by two and a half and
you get an idea of what those Pilots
were dealing with
and they struggle to understand it they
couldn't figure out what was going on
and those warnings weren't really
helping them understand why the plane
was actually pitching down and why they
couldn't fix it
but this isn't a surprise to anyone
right this is a known issue right this
is what I did a lot of my PhD research
in this is what people have been doing
researching for 50 years particularly at
Nasa for spacecraft and we know that
this is a problem
based on lessons learned from past
Airline accidents the FAA regulations
have precise design details on how to
deal with these things and they are
aimed at ensuring three things that the
pilot knows what is going on that it
catches their attention and it averts
any possible confusion now the second
one there is very easy to do as I showed
you in that video it's easy to catch
someone's attention you just make a loud
noise or shake their their control stick
but doing that in combination with one
and three is much more difficult right
how do you get their attention in a way
that does not distract them from
actually understanding what you're
trying to convey to them
and these regulations they didn't just
come out of nowhere these are Written in
Blood right like these are from past
accidents and that is why we have these
rules
in 2014 Boeing convinced the FAA to
relax the standards for the 737 Max
related to the cockpit alerts that would
warn the pilots if something went wrong
their justification for this was because
the aircraft the airframe is so old and
we're only trying to change this one
part of the design it would be cost
prohibitive for us to try to upgrade
this entire thing to meet the standards
the FAA said
okay
and that was it that was the end of it
they were completely okay with that and
that is one of the reasons that they're
at the front at the beginning I said
Boeing and the FAA both played equal
roles in this in these tragedies
this is not a solution like I'm saying
I'm not telling you what you should or
should not do when you design your
systems because obviously this is a very
difficult and complex problem that is
not solved in any way but there are
plenty of good guidelines and standards
and and recommendations for how to
design Warning Systems in a way that
doesn't overload your Pilots so that is
just something you need to consider when
you're working on a system like this
let's talk about manual override
particularly for MCAS
did MCAS have a manual override was it
used appropriately
let's talk about levels of automation
now this is a concept that has had a
very extensive amount of research on it
there are
different scales ranging from 3 to 12
plus different levels of automation
depending on which scientist you ask
but I've kind of condensed it down into
four primary levels here
your first one being a system that
provides helpful information so you tell
it what you want or it guesses what you
want and it provides you information
that could help you do it right so your
your Google Maps is a good example it's
not driving your car for you it's not
making you turn left and right on the
sidewalk it's just telling you what you
should do to meet your objective
your second level is automatic control
when directed by a human the cruise
control in your car it doesn't turn
itself on when you turn it on it
automates things until you turn it off
or it meets some end conditions such as
touching the brakes
your third level is automatic control
unless directed by a human Windows
update is a great example it will do its
thing
and it will restart your computer at the
worst possible time unless you manually
intervene to stop it from doing so
and then your fourth level is automatic
control with no human override and this
is a much harder to come up with an
example for because there are relatively
few systems in the world that don't have
some big red emergency stop button
that'll shut down the automation
but where we start to see this is
particularly in space flight if you
remember the New Horizons probe that
went past Pluto and it took all those
really cool photos that entire procedure
where it did a lot of different
movements to aim the camera at different
things that was all choreographed in
advance and once it started there was no
way for a human to to stop it because of
latency and even if they did want to
stop it there's no way a person can
think fast enough to tell it what it
should do instead
where does MCAS fit on this
we could say that it's three level three
because it automatically does its thing
unless the human turns off that cutoff
switch
but is that is that cutoff switch really
disabling the automation
it's not all it's doing is it's
unhooking the automation from the thing
it's supposed to be controlling but the
automation is still running there in the
background
and by unhooking that or using that
breaker that breaks the connection they
were also disabling other critical
functionality which is their their
electric toggle switch that controls the
trim so is it really a manual override
if you can't use it without disabling a
bunch of other critical systems and such
that when you reconnect it it's still
failing right from the start
redundancy not so much to do with humans
and Technology but we've spent all this
time talking about the plans we need to
mention and certainly relevant for what
we do in this conference
who here
can see the redundancy failure in the
systems diagram
oh man okay a couple hands all right
so in case you here can you see this
there we go right here
this sensor is connected to one computer
one computer is active at a time this
sensor isn't doing squat over there it's
not its data isn't even being used so
when that first sensor fails
your system's broke right the flight
control computers the pilots can
manually switch from one to the other in
the case of a computer failure but when
the sensor breaks the computer doesn't
know that the sensor broke and so it
can't tell the pilots that the sensor
broke and the pilots don't know that
they should switch to the other computer
so we have a single point of failure
here in that angle of attack sensor
and we can see that more obviously in
this graph
these are our two sensors this is data
they pulled off the flight data recorder
and we can see that the left sensor is
the red line the right sensor is the
black well we can guess which sensor was
connected to the active flight computer
at the time
so where the where the reading spikes up
is where we think that A bird hit it and
broke it off
but what do you actually do about this
well first off do not ever let assist
critical system have a single point of
failure right we're working on a lot of
a lot of critical embedded systems with
people in this room I'm sure most of are
already aware of this
but the less common one is don't let a
broken sensor affect good sensors here
we had a good sensor that was still
getting good data we could have used it
but we didn't
but what happens when you do that how do
you deal with those two sensors
disagreeing with each other well ideally
you'd add a third sensor and you'd have
some sort of consensus mechanism right
like a lot of distributed systems use a
an approach like this
but you can't always do that there could
be technical limitations
um there could be it could be cost
prohibitive it's always a trade-off
between cost and and performance
so maybe we do something like forcing a
manual override we can read the two
sensors and we can alert the pilots that
hey these things aren't agreeing
something is out of whack one of these
is broken we don't know which one so we
can't automate anything so that you the
pilot you need to take over
that could work and I would probably
would have worked in this situation but
the problem here is that imagine you're
flying your plane Along on autopilot and
all of a sudden the automation kicks off
you have no idea why and your plane just
starts drifting off to the side you need
to take control
and you start getting into this mode
confusion situation again because now
you are not aware of what mode your
airplane is is in why the autopilot
failed and why you are now required to
take control of it
so it's hard right this is not again not
a solution it's just talking about a lot
of these problems you really need to
think about because they're all
interconnected it's this tangled web of
problems where to solve one you make the
other worse
change management again not so human
related unless you're considering the
engineers to be the humans in your
system
in this so MCAS was originally designed
to only operate under very specific
conditions basically if you're if your
aircraft was flying at a fair at
cruising speed and somehow pitched up
too high and started to get into that
reinforcement loop with the lift in the
front then the system would kick in
and it did this by requiring two
different sensors you had the angle of
attack sensor that I talked about and a
G-Force sensor because if you're flying
at a high speed and you pitch up all of
a sudden that's quite a G-Force uh
change and your sensor will trigger
but what happened is the pilots when
they were the test pilots when they were
doing takeoffs in this aircraft they
thought or they said to to Boeing this
does this feels weird right
um and when MCAS activates we like that
it helps with the with the flight
control so give us more MCAS right make
it happen more often uh it helps us with
with controlling the takeoffs
so Boeing said okay we're going to have
MCAS applied during the takeoff phase as
well but the problem is that during
takeoff the plane is moving at low speed
which means there are no real g-forces
to deal with so they had to disable the
g-force sensor so that MCAS could work
during a takeoff phase so now you have a
system like this that is only activated
by a single sensor
the other issue is that when you're
moving at low speed
during the takeoff phase
when you're moving at low speed a
control surface on an aircraft has to
move more to have the same effect
because there's less air moving over it
so they had to increase the power of
MCAS as well
so when the plants finally entered
service MCAS was able to move the tail
four times further than was stated in
the initial safety analysis document so
they did their safety analysis on this
system and then they removed one of the
triggers and then they quadrupled the
power and at no point did they redo the
safety analysis
how did that get through a change
management system
retiring a system
now I think given the nature of this
conference in C plus plus and C A lot of
people in here have probably
pretty familiar with Legacy Legacy
systems right I bet a lot of people in
here have been working on Fortran or
cobalt-based systems in the not too
recent past not too distant past
I I think at some point an engineer
needs to recognize when something has
reached its limits when it is unsafe to
push it further when to when trying to
add new features is just going to break
everything and possibly kill people
Boeing had this thought right in 2006
they said we've pushed this plan to its
limits we need a new design but because
of Market pressures because of poor
management because of a culture where
people couldn't speak up
it made it through as a additional model
that was past its design limits it was
not built to handle engines of that size
so we come to kind of our
responsibilities as developers and
Engineers what do we do about this
unless you're some high level executive
in a company like Boeing you're not
going to have a whole lot of sway but
when someone asks you to develop
something and you think should I really
quadruple the power of this system or
remove this safety check without
doing anything about it to evaluate
whether it's safe you probably need to
raise your voice about that
at Boeing
they couldn't the engineers actually a
number of Engineers tried to do that and
resigned from Boeing when they couldn't
Boeing at the time their management
penalized Engineers from writing safety
concerns in in emails in case it could
show up in court later they would dock
your bonus pay if you wrote up a safety
concern in writing
that is not a healthy culture to work in
and I strongly encourage you if you're
working on a system like this and you're
facing that kind of issue find a new
employer it's a hot Market out there
you'll have no problem with it
because what I guarantee you don't want
is to feel the way a lot of Engineers at
Boeing do right now or previous
engineers at Boeing with the weight of
those deaths on your shoulders for the
rest of your career and I'm not saying
you need to do all these things for your
next WordPress install
but if you're working on anything where
a life could be involved absolutely
there's these are things that need to be
considered
so with that thank you for your time uh
it's been a pleasure talking to you
about it hopefully it was fun enough for
the party atmosphere
um this is my email here email me with
anything you want I'm happy to talk
about it I'll be here the rest of the
evening so come up and talk to me as
well if you'd like to chat
um there's a QR code for top tell if
you're interested you can get a pretty
hefty bonus if you have certain skills
um thank you for your time
since yeah since there's no one really
after me other than a C plus plus quiz
in half an hour
um I'm happy to take any questions that
anyone has or would like to chat about
so we have a
company
do we have any people that have been
implemented about the
could have been implemented
oh that's a good question uh there were
pardon
uh the question was so we discovered
this secret unsafe system that had been
built into the aircraft have there been
any other situations where we have
discovered due to an accident or some
other cause a different secret system
that shouldn't have been there in terms
of Secrets yes there are and I know that
I've studied them I can't remember
specific names but in this aircraft in
particular during so when it was
grounded obviously Boeing and the FAA we
were humiliated by this spent all of
their resources thoroughly investigating
this plan and what's actually kind of
funny about it is that this plane is
probably one of the safest aircraft to
fly in now because it is one of the only
aircraft in the last
few decades that has gone through such
intense scrutiny and so we actually know
that it's probably not going to fail
um but during that investigation phase
they found quite a few other issues they
found metal fragments in the fuel tanks
um and some other I think there was
another algorithm issue they found as
well that they had to fix so yeah there
are plenty of problems that get
discovered
but shouldn't uh FAA extend if they
require uh redundancy or performance
in theory yeah uh it's
doesn't the FAA require redundancy on
all components of a plane
yeah so it's three systems for critical
systems
if the safety analysis or the
engineering defines it as something that
if it fails the plane will crash then it
requires three systems so that's
generally Hydraulics and certain other
flight Control Systems what happened
here is that Boeing said this is not a
critical system because if it fails the
pilots can still fly the plane
so it didn't meet that requirement for
having to be redundant
the same type
yeah it's still the same type
basically they altered
this part I haven't researched as much
but I believe what happened is they they
altered the MCAS algorithm to not
trigger as often and they added
redundancy between these two sensors and
basically they ended up coming back to
their original argument of a pilot
doesn't interact with the system so they
don't need to train on it
hell no yeah
yeah
with with what
ah so uh here let me pull up
actually I don't have an Airbus diagram
here but
um
if we look at this so the 737 uh the
wings are mounted very low on the
fuselage right they're quite low to the
ground then it was designed that way for
aerodynamic reasons when they were using
Small Engines the seven or sorry the
A320 is a newer aircraft it's still very
old but it was designed with the wings
mounted much higher on the fuse sludge
so they actually had plenty of space
under the wings to mount the newer
engines and didn't have to do the whole
shift forward and up situation
yeah
there were against Boeing yep uh the
they were charged with trying to defraud
the FAA
well I'm not exactly sure how the
corporate government works governance
works I think when a corporation gets
charged some of the executives
take responsibility for that but
um I don't think any individuals were
and they were charged but it was settled
out of court for 2.5 million and I
believe one of the reasons for settling
out of court is that if Boeing was had a
criminal record they can't provide
things for the federal government
anymore and Boeing is one of the only
providers of certain types of spacecraft
and stuff so it was a huge deal yeah
yeah
sole sourcing it's great
any others oh another one
I'm not alert I would agree with you but
I have no jurisdiction there what's
interesting that you mentioned the
culture and this is something I don't
really have time to talk about in the
talk but it's kind of fun to talk about
after feel free to go get beer or food
or whatever you want by the way
um is that so Boeing historically has
been the opposite right they have been
very engineer driven uh and had a very
strong culture of of Engineers bringing
concerns forward and having more of a
Collegiate relationship instead of a
top-down relationship uh in
1997 I believe they merged with mcdougs
yeah uh and with Doug McDonald
something Douglas yeah and um that
company had the opposite culture and
even though Boeing I believe acquired
Douglas
um the Douglas CEO became the Boeing CEO
and so that whole management style was
replicated throughout Boeing and so you
see this trend over the next five ten
years of all the really good Engineers
bailing because they couldn't they
didn't want to be part of this new
culture and you get things like the 737
Max yeah
just one thing um
that illustrates The Importance of Being
Honest because well in the short term
money of being dishonest at the long run
uh it's not just the Boeing but you also
have the diesel gate on Volkswagen uh
that means that in the long run being
dishonest with equality can be very
expensive and it can even ruin a company
yeah but it's a question of how do you
define long run and if you have a CEO
and you're already 70 and you're only
going to be there for five more years do
you really care about the long run or do
you care about your retirement package
which is based on stock price
and it's part of I mean there's a whole
bunch of issues around Corporate America
that we can go into at a later time but
um yeah there's no motivation for
long-term uh success really yeah
all right I think that's everything
thank you again and I'll see you around
out there